the game of thrones prequel series house
of the dragon although based on georgia
or martin's targaryen history book fire
and blood
will not feature targaryens only but
many other houses and many other
legendary figures from that time period
as well
including thailand lannister who in
opinion of many was the hardest and most
loyal guy of them all
this guy was literally tortured at one
point in most horrific ways
and yet refused to betray the secrets of
his sworn king
if there's any man that served the hand
of the kingrowl as good and efficient as
diamond lannister did to the mad king
then it's thailand lannister thailand
fought for queen ellis and son aegon the
second and the greens
but also sir the blacks and rhaenyra's
son aegon iii
and yet he never broke an oath and
remains one of the most loyal characters
in the history of westeros
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by
hbo's president where in 2022 mikvel
sapochnick and ryan condell will serve
as showrunners and executive producers
george rr martin will also serve as
executive producer
it's based on georgia r martin's book
fire and blood volume 1
and on martin's yet unfinished fire and
blood volume 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary aegon the conqueror
creator of the iron throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
that's fire and blood vol 1. the
ethanolist fire and blood volume 2 will
continue from where part 1
ended with rhinera targaryen son aegon
iii
reign and will cover blackfyre
rebellions the war we dorne
and go all the way to the mad king and
robert's rebellion that ended targaryen
dynasty
the key event of the show is also the
key in a history of house targaryen
the dance of the dragons the targaryen
civil war
which divided the entire kingdom and
launched a huge war that was fought from
129 ac to 131ac
the dance of the dragons was the most
devastating war in the history of the
seven kingdoms
a war of succession between aegon ii and
his half-sister rhaenyra
over their father viserys the first
round
both of them thought they belonged on
the iron throne when people
started declaring for one of them or the
other their fight divided the kingdoms
in two
targaryens fought targaryens brothers
fought brothers
dragons fought the dragons by the time
it was over
thousands were dead before targaryen
civil war started
and thus in season one sir thailand
lannister is a knight from house
lannister
he serves on the small council at king's
landing as master of ships for king
viserys the first targaryen
but throughout his life he will also
serve as a master of coin
for aegon ii targaryen and as the hand
of the king for aegon iii
targaryen he's a younger twin brother of
jason lannister
the lord of casterly rock when the dance
of the dragon starts thailand is one of
the most prominent
enemies of rhaenyra but in his youth to
be more precise in 112 ac
sir thailand and his older twins are
jason white for the hand of princess
rhaenyra targaryen but with no success
eventually thailand was named the master
of ships by rhaenyra's father
king viserys the first targaryen on the
night of death of king viserys the first
targaryen
thailand gathered with the other members
of the small council and queen ellis and
hightower chambers
there they discussed the succession
until dawn
during the meeting thailand pointed out
that many of the lords who had sworn to
defend the succession of princess
rhaenyra back in 105 ac
were long dead he remarked that it had
been 24 years
and that he himself swore no such oath
as he had been a child at the time and
sided with alison's son aegon
to make him king rather than have
rhaenyra as the queen of the seven
kingdoms
at the start of the dance of the dragons
sir thailand was named master of coin by
deutscher queen ellison hightower upon
his appointment
thailand acted at once to seize the
royal treasury which proved to be one of
the best
decisions the greens have made during
this entire war
but also a decision that would later be
the reason of a horrendous torture upon
him
the crown's gold was divided into four
parts
one part was entrusted to the care of
the iron bank of braavos for
safe keeping another sent to castroli
rock
and the third to old town the remaining
wealth was used by the greens for bribes
and gifts and hiring sellswords
when king aegon got severely wounded in
a dragon fight
and prince aymond targaryen was the
prince regent and protector of the realm
thailand favored amen's suggestion of
bringing battle to prince damon
targaryen
and fighting rebellious river lords this
proved to be the biggest mistake the
greens could do
by leading an entire army and the
biggest dragon bagar out of king's
landing to fight daemon in the
riverlands
aemond gave daemon rhaenyra's husband
and the most experienced general in
westeros an opportunity to avoid the
aemond
and instead go for the defenseless
king's landing
and to put his wife ryanair on the iron
throne which he did
when rhaenyra took king's landing in 130
ac
thailand was among the members of the
court who emerged from maegor's holdfest
thailand was taken and given to
rhaenyra's torturers
in hopes that some of the crown's
treasury could be recovered
however thailand lannister proved to be
the most loyal man in westeros
and refused to tell where the gold had
been sent
despite being blinded guilded and
mutilated by tortures
after yet another fall of king's landing
and after rhaenyra fled the capital
sir thailand was released by the gutter
knights of serperkin the flea
who had seized the red keep to install
his squire through staying through fire
as king on the iron throne after the
city was taken back by the greens
thailand was reinstalled as master of
coin
as the armies of the north the vale and
the riverlands all loyal to queen
rhaenyra were preparing to march on
king's landing
thailand suggested sailing to lis or
tyrosh
to hire sellsword companies to fight for
aegon ii
but coralists valerian insisted that
thailand could never return with the
sellswords in time
when king aegon ii suggested sending
reinhair a son
prince aegon the younger to the wall or
gelding him
to ensure rhaenyra's line would end with
her only remaining son
thailand argued for harsher course he
suggested aegon's execution
insisting that aegon would always be a
threat to the king
as long as he lived thailand was later
dispatched across the narrow sea to find
cell swords in pantos tyrosh and mere
thailand returned to king's landing from
mir shortly after king aegon ii
targaryen's death
he was made a hand of the king for the
very same guy he wanted to execute
king aegon iii targaryen at the start of
his regency
he began wearing a silken hood over his
head on formal occasions
as ladies new to court were known to
faint when seeing his face
the result of all the torture rhaenyra's
men did to him
his hood however gave cause to whispers
among the small folk
who considered him a malign mask
sorcerer and began calling him
the hooded hand despite having
previously served king aegon ii
and having argued for the death of aegon
iii before his coronation
and despite the fact that aegon iii's
mother tortured him
thailand served the new king loyally
thailand set
out to restore trade to the seven
kingdoms which had collapsed during the
war
he abolished taxes that had been enacted
by queen rhaenyra targaryen
and lord bartimos sultigar gave out
loans for rebuilding the holdings which
had been destroyed during the war
and ordered the construction of three
huge fortified granaries throughout the
kingdom
and had them filled with grain he also
ordered the repair and
restoration of the dragon pit
strengthened the city gates
and announced funding for the
construction of 50 new war
galleys although only 10 were eventually
commissioned
when war erupted once more in the
stepstones
thailand refused the offers made by
envoys from panthos braavos and lorath
to form an alliance against the
legendary pirate roccaliarindon
insisting to the regents of fagon iii
that it was wiser to keep
out of the wars of the free cities in
nearly 1 30 3 a.c when it was discovered
that winter fever had broken out
across the city and realm thailand
ordered the gates of the city and the
red keep closed
to prevent the disease from spreading
but as the winter fever was nearing its
end
thailand himself fell ill he died after
only two days in the presence of
septon eustace and king aegon iii who
took his hand as thailand took his last
breath
thailand is one of the most important
characters in this story
by moving three quarters of the crown's
gold from king's landing
while aegon the second master of coin
thailand had sown the seeds of queen
rhaenyra's downfall
a stroke of cunning that would in the
end cost him his eyes ears and health
and caused the dragon queen her throne
and her very life
yet it must be said that he served
rhaenyra sunvell and faithfully
thailand lannister will definitely be
one of the most interesting characters
in the house of the dragon
an honorable man who lives and breeds
for the realm
dutiful as it gets thailand's loyalty is
that big
that he enters the war healthy as it
gets but at the end of the targaryen
civil
war his blind broken eunuch for he never
betrayed the side he fought for
all of this and more the game of thrones
prequel show house of the dragon brings
in 2022
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video please give it a big
thumbs up
and i hope to see you in the next one
peace